emmanuel sarrazin un médecin généraliste
cofondateur du collectif médecin c'est
bonsoir emmanuel sarrazin merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
vous êtes à l'origine on l'appelle de la
plainte déposée par six ans praticien
l'encontre du premier ministre et de
l'ex ministre de la santé pour mensonge
d'état
vous vous disais vous même lanceur d
alerte est ce que aujourd'hui vous
lancer l' alerte à propos de la
résurgence de cas à pékin
bonsoir non je pense que pékin allait
mesurer on le voit ici
ce qu'il faut c'est à dire qu'ils vont
tester le plus de personnes possible et
ils ont mis en quarantaine déjà la zone
incriminée
c'est un cluster comme on peut et on en
aura sans doute en france aussi mais là
bas on voit qu et moyens ont été mis
c'est-à-dire tester les gens et être
confiné de façon raisonnable la zone
incriminée
donc vous êtes confiant quand on parle
de ça se passe en chine
ça va se passer de la même manière ça va
venir on n'aura pas prêt vous tenez à
rassurer ces personnes créatives
oui moi je pense que avant de parler
deuxième vague on peut parler d'un gros
cluster on aura forcément en europe
aussi et en france aussi je pense qu'on
m'enlève déjà eu dans les jours
précédents des clusters important le
seul problème chez nous c'est le
problème de manque de test et
ce manque de rigueur dans le confinement
cibler des gens testé positivement corps
ce qu'on aurait dû faire déjà dès le
début ça va pas aujourd'hui clairement
et magasins les gens susceptibles d'être
contaminés sont testés mais si j'ose
dire d'après le service après vente
entre guillemets pardonnez moi cette
expression ne se fait pas bien alors je
dis d'abord qui ne teste pas encore de
façon assez massive
actuellement on n'est pas au nombre de
tests voluer annoncées par le
gouvernement comme depuis le début c'est
comme des masques on nous avait promis
des tests nombreux est en finale on
s'aperçoit qu'on a du mal à tester les
gens et deuxièmement oui les mesures de
confinement pour l'instant ont été de
manière générale mais pas de manière
ciblée il sent que on va y venir mais on
attend de voir
on va y venir c'est à dire c'est à dire
que quand les gens sont testés
positivement il faudrait un les isolés
soit chez eux soit dans des structures
adaptées type des hôtels des centres de
vacances testé après selon des cercles
les proches et ainsi de suite et isolé
tout ce monde là avant résulte en
attendant le résultat des tests et ne
donnait l'autorisation de sortie de
travail d'aller à l'école qu'après quoi
est pour l'instant en tout cas nous à
notre niveau on n'a pas cette mise en
place et pourtant les vielles véran
disait il ya quelques jours 700
militaires mais on ne va pas forcément
tous les utiliser parce que on en a pas
forcément le besoin qui d'amy est en
train de de s'éloigner ça veut dire
selon vous qu on est un petit peu trop
voilà trop laxiste on n'est pas assez
prenants pourtant le gouvernement tente
d'appeler clairement
régulièrement la prudence il appelle à
la prudence mais depuis le départ on a
quand même un vent de panique et des
mesures qui sont contradictoires
au départ il fallait pas de masque un
jour appelle au départ il allait tester
que les malades non il faut pas testé
que les malades il faut tester aussi
tout cela il aurait fallu tester aussi
le plus de personnes possible afin
d'éviter justement que les gens tombent
malades
donc on est un petit peu dans une
incohérence et un manque d'organisation
depuis le début sous l'effet de la
panique je pense j'ose l'espérer
en tout cas on n'était pas prêts on ne
l'est toujours pas puisque on est
toujours en pénurie de masques on a
toujours autant de mal ce toit se
trouvaient des masques les patients de
nombreux patients cité quant aux tests
bah c'est pas 700 milles qui sont faits
comme comme il est dit alors on revient
au début de notre interview on va la
refaire mais comme ça qu'est ce que
c'était l'objet de votre invitation
ce entre guillemets vous vous la paix
cluster à pékin à nouveau c'est un
marché alimentaire qui est suspecté pour
vous est ce qu'on en fait assez
justement on se dit voilà pour la
deuxième fois c'est un marché
alimentaire qui est suspecté est ce que
les autorités chinois sont invités
voilà au revoir peut-être leur méthode
en chine
je ne sais pas quelles sont leurs
méthodes je les connais pas en tout cas
c'est sûr qu'il faut faire attention
c'est que le virus a une durée de vie
sur des matériaux inertes qui peuvent
aller de sur plusieurs jours
effectivement il ya des mesures
d'hygiène à respecter est ce qu'ils sont
respectés en chine je ne sais pas en
tout cas je sais qu'en france dans sur
les marchés il ya des mesures de
d'hygiène qui sont qui sont mises en
place depuis confinement et il faut
continuer à les respecter puisque la
première chose en finale sur les mesures
barrières qui nous protège tous et
protège de la propagation du virus